la carapace de nicolas dos reis s'est
brisé hier soir il a enfin reconnu sa
responsabilité et son geste
ils ont tous les deux mis le feu aux
poubelles du foyer cette nuit du 14
novembre 2010 des larmes ont coulé sur
son visage le jeune homme s'est livré à
la cour
mon avis par rapport à sa réaction c'est
qu'il a évolué pressé par la
multiplicité des questions mais qu'on
n'est pas encore arrivé au bout de la
vérité je crois qu'il retient encore des
choses une vérité mise en doute car rémi
kukulinski maintient une autre version
des faits il reconnaît sa part de
responsabilité mais accuse toujours
nicolas d'être seul responsable de la
mise à feu
il reste sur sa position mais il n'a
jamais varié depuis la première minute
le garde à vue il a dis toujours la même
chose
c'est peut-être que c'est la vérité
notre client nicolas de stress n'a aucun
avantage à tirer du fait de dire je les
fais où il l'a pas fait il a participé
n'a pas contribué
simplement je pense que ça serait bon
pour chacun qu il reconnaisse
intégralement et peut-être qu'on a des
choses encore à apprendre d'une autre je
ne le dit pas mais que chacun
reconnaisse véritablement c'est l'effet
qu'il acquit là qu'il a commis alors à
qui la faute
il reste encore dix jours de procès pour
tenter d'en savoir plus l'audience
reprendra à lundi à 9 heures